there's only one task on this workbench
to save life their focus here has
switched from vacuum cleaners and garden
tools to ventilators that can help
people breathe one week after the
government made a public appeal for help
GTECH in Worcestershire have their
prototype almost ready this is day two
of 24-hour testing we think we've solved
all the difficult bits we're just making
the last bits of a pneumatic timer now
which hopefully be ready in a few hours
if that works we can take all the
electronics off it and it will just run
off still supplies that's very simple
I'm confirm we can build them in
reasonably short time I'd estimated a
thousand a day the lesson from Italy is
that if you run out of ventilators
clinicians have to make incredibly hard
decisions
so there are now people across the UK
racing to avoid that scenario
RDM automotive in Coventry normally
produced driverless cars but they're now
on hold as their engineers develop their
own ventilator we are able to kill it
eventually and in the old type of spirit
of the wall we have to run around and we
will have to help each other and we have
their loved ones and that's what we're
trying to do experts at the McLaren
Formula One team are just one part of
another ventilator production consortium
they told Sky News the designs of a
preferred solution are due to be
released imminently and when they are
the consortium stands ready to begin
production on these immediately GTECH
have been told by the government that
the NHS needs 30 thousand extra
ventilators history shows us that
moments of crisis can bring out the very
best of British ingenuity and this
workshop like many others around the UK
are on this challenge full-time at the
moment and they are confident that the
need within the NHS can be met the
prototype here hasn't missed a beat
yet it has its temperature taken
regularly and if it is approved full
production could be just days away
Tom Parmenter Sky News Worcestershire